women's cycling Champion Hannah renzman
quit the sport of losing to
controversial transgender competitor
Austin killins in December abandoning
her dream of competing in the Paris
Olympics in 2024 footage from that race
shows killip's shoving Arrangement
causing outrage that the six foot tall
very muscular born male
used intimidation to get ahead but last
weekend Austin Killers won another race
in North Carolina by five entire minutes
in a moment I'll get the view of former
Olympic swimming champion and author of
a new book unfair play Sharon Davis but
first i'm joined by Hannah arenzman from
United States Hannah when you see just
that bit of footage there the the brutal
way was sort of shoved away but in a way
that's kind of what's happening in
women's sport generally right a bunch of
trans athletes have come along and are
shoving biological females out the way
absolutely that's it's very
disheartening to see in all sorts of
levels and it's not just the elite it's
also every level starting from open
women all the way up so yeah it's very
sad honey you've actually quit the sport
which is incredibly depressing that
you've been forced to do this why did
you come to that decision
there are multiple reasons but it was
definitely very disheartening to leave
my last race and be flanked on either
side
of the national cycle cross championship
by two men on the elite women's race
and these are men who are now trans
women but they're biological men and
this is an issue now not just affecting
cycling but we're seeing it in all sorts
of other sports do you feel Hannah
obviously it's such a Hot Topic it's so
incendiary very few people want to put
their heads over the parapet do you feel
a lot of female athletes and sports
women share your view but are just too
intimidated to say it
yes Lots even in the SCI in the side
Community which
the front
it's very Pro guys racing in our field
but the women quietly
try to find ways to let their voice be
heard by either contacting the governing
bodies or just trying to make other
people wear around that this is not okay
it's not fair and biologically you can
never make it fair it's completely
unfair well thank you very much indeed
uh and I'm just so sorry about what's
happened to you Sharon let me come to
you because you've written this great
book The Battle of a women's sport
that's what it is it's a battle for the
heart and soul in Integrity of a sport
that you Grace so brilliantly I mean
I go back to when you got cheated out of
a gold medal at the Olympics because of
the doping that was going on with with
the East uh Germans wasn't it at the
time and you should have won Gold and
you didn't because you had a bunch of
doping cheats uh at the time is it that
different now well it's exactly the same
except it's a different process you know
what what happened way back then in the
70s and the 80s that they were taking 11
and 12 year old girls and giving them
testosterone and putting them through a
male puberty and they totally and
utterly dominated for 20 years the IFC
did nothing so to the level of the
European championships they won 90 of
the women's medals you know just
stratopheric you know improvements and
perhaps nothing in the men's and so that
was because they were given this
additional testosterone which is still
less than what you would have if you
were a biologically male so we're now
asking our female athletes to race
people that have gone through the whole
of puberty there's 17 peer-reviewed
studies out there not a single one says
that we can remove you know that male
biology and that and that Advantage so
we're knowingly making our girls race
against an advantage before they even
start which the men are never asked to
do and that's what's so frustrating is
that the men would not put up with this
and also there's no issue with trans men
right competing against biological don't
because they can't yeah they don't
that's why we separate the Sexes at the
Olympics I mean that's why we do it
that's exactly it you know we have
categories and all sorts of things we
have obviously the biggest one is male
female then we have all the weight
categories we have all the
paralympicions the worst thing shown is
that very mediocre competitors when they
identify as their biological sex
then become World beaters when they put
their hands up and say I'm now a woman
yeah and compete against biological
females that's my problem with it it's
just then often they're not very good
competing as men but as women they're
World beaters yeah that's the thing you
know something like swimming it's 11 the
difference between male and female
performance so you get someone like Leah
Thomas who was
460 ship in America over 2 000 in the
world would never have made nc2a finals
which is the Collegiate files in America
competing as a man transitions for one
year and beats three American Olympic
silver medalists it's ridiculous it is
it's actually maddening and what's even
more maddening people like you and I've
what I've followed I'm so glad you come
on the show because I've been trying to
get you for ages just to say thank you
for what you've been doing thank you
because I've watched the abuse that
comes your way right the the viciousness
the you're a bigger you're a transphob
almost it's all complete nonsense you're
just standing up for women's rights to
equality it's really what you do do it
and I'm not anti-trans at all you know I
believe we should have the debate find a
place for everybody to do sport I love
sports it's been my life I want everyone
to be able to do sport however it must
be fair and safe it must be safe first
then it must be fair then we will find
ways to be inclusive and I've always
advocated for the female Caspian and
open category you know you mentioned
trans men and trans men that are on
testosterone have nowhere to race and no
one ever talks about them because they
don't matter because they're females
right but actually if we have this open
category they would have so much to
raise as well yeah I think they're you
either compete against your biological
sex so if you're a trans woman you
compete against biological males as many
of them have done before or you have a
different category of his own yeah what
you can't do you cannot continue to
allow biological males to demolish
biological females otherwise the
Integrity of women's sport is
disintegrated I know and it's not just
that it's the
small piece of a cake anyway peers you
know in this country for example there's
a thousand women earning their living
from sport there's eleven thousand men
in America one percent of the
sponsorship dollar goes to women one
percent yeah four percent goes in a
Prime Time Sports airtime our piece of
the cake is Tiny and now we're being
asked to budge over for biological males
it's it's just infuriating and the book
shows throughout the whole history this
has been the case no no it's brilliantly
researched but I I do come back to this
thing that basically it's the new form
of doping it's the new form of cheating
everybody knows it gives them an unfair
advantage and it's not transphobic I
support trans people's rights to
fairness and equality but why should
that come at the expense of fairness
safety inequality for women it shouldn't
no it really shouldn't you know we
fought very hard to try and get equality
we're nowhere near it but we are getting
there and now this is a massive step
backwards and it is a parallel with
those East German years it is that's
probably why I speak out because I saw
so many of my friends you know lose that
I have friends that came forth behind
three East Germans no one's ever
remembered and I read that you met the
East German who beat you and she
recently and she offered to give you her
medal yeah she did so she knew yeah they
did know you know they know that they
were part of a system right they were
part of a system I don't have any issues
with them as individuals at all in fact
you know I believe they were very much
victims of the system yeah I agree the
IRC are extremely responsible for all of
this they are not the IRC are not to be
held up as examples I totally agree keep
doing this thank you very much because
you're doing an incredibly important job
and it's a brave and lonely place to be
it's getting better it's getting busier
it is and eventually justice will
prevail and Common Sense will prevail
it's called the battle for women's sport
unfair play by Sharon Davis a fantastic
book if you want to know why it's so
unfair and why it's so important to have
this debate and to avoid all the
nonsensical abuse that goes with it read
this book Sharon good to see you thank
you